President Trump wants to have a second
round of talks with Russian President
Vladimir Putin in Washington this fall
the Trump administration is in its
fourth day of damage control after the
president's meeting with Putin in
Finland we saw Jiang is at the White
House with new information about this
week's summit we J good morning good
morning John last night Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo said presidents Trump
and Putin made progress on a number of
issues and Russia says it's already
prepared to implement agreements but a
White House official tells CBS News the
only deal actually reached was to have a
second summit meanwhile the president's
own leader of the intelligence community
says he's still in the dark we have some
breaking news the White House has
announced on Twitter that Vladimir Putin
is coming to the White House in the fall
president Trump's own Director of
National Intelligence dan coates was
clearly shocked to find out the
president had invited Putin to
Washington for a second meeting code
said he has no idea what the president
and Putin talked about during their
one-on-one which Coates believes should
not have been private you'd ask me how
that ought to be conducted I would have
suggested a different way there was
progress made on a handful of friends
last night Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo fired back at criticism that the
President appeared week by meeting with
Putin on Monday the president's been
very resolute he understands precisely
who it is we're dealing with in Russia
at the summit Putin offered the u.s.
permission to interview 12 Russians
accused of interfering in the 2016
election in exchange for allowing his
investigators to question American
citizens including former US ambassador
to Moscow Michael McFaul and American
financier William Broder I think that's
an incredible offer on Thursday the
White House walked back the president's
remark now saying he disagrees with
proposal Brodeur a longtime critic of
Putin says that reversal does not go far
enough
he needs to be much more explicit about
how this is never gonna happen after the
White House backtracked on the
president's initial remark the Senate
unanimously voted against allowing
Russians to interview US officials whom
reportedly told Russian diplomats he
also proposed to President Trump a
referendum to help resolve the conflict
in eastern Ukraine but pentagon
officials say they have not received any
new guidance and existing law makes it
illegal for the u.s. to work with Russia
there gaile all right we should thank
you very much